コーラー
それはおそらく世界で最も愛されているであろう
炭酸飲料のことであるその独特な黒い色からは想像もできないような素敵な香り
そしてふーみー味すべてが税世界の人間を魅了し今や清涼飲料水のトップに君臨する
伝説のドリンクそれがコーラで
ああ
しかし
そのコーラの作り方は未だ秘密のままであり誰一人一
知ることはなかった
ウルグアイはドクター端ねー
みんなは面喰って呼びけどねぇなこの句がコーラ学んだら作り方は誰もわかっちゃい
ねえ
この味を現実的に再現するのは100%無理だ
と思っていたやハッハー
クネはそそるぜドクターストーンという漫画あってそれのアニメ俺見てたんですけど
そこで俺は前に3つ消えちまったんだ
どこでも買えるようなものでコーラを作る方法
これはそそる they are あの
すごくないですかなんかまたそっちで聞いたことあるんですけども
コーラ作るのってなる企業秘めてみたいなもう完全に秘密になってて
コーランの原料とか何も知られてないんですけどもドクターと何を見てたらですね様々
つの主人公の戦空がこう作ったそれをなんかどこにでもてれるような芸術時代の場所で
まあこのは授与さクリルって混ぜすごいすそんななか企業秘密的な事を知っていいのか
なと思いつつも書いてあったんです今日は作ってみようと思いま免空の科学の実験江寧
始まりでえっ
そそる勢もやっぱり的で必要なものを出していきましょう本当にアニメに書いてあった
通りで作ってみましょう
まずは炭酸水原作だとこれがすごい大変そうでしたね炭酸作るのすごい大変なんですよ
実は蜂蜜
ライムパクチーなんかカラメルソースも必要なんですけども作るのめんどくさそうだっ
たんでアメリカカスタードプリンの中に入ってましたこれを使わせていただきます
パネリストこれだけ
でコーラ作れるって書いておりました
あんなに企業秘密とは言ってたのに毒竜と何も見えたら普通に売ってたそれを作りたく
なったわ
ただけで本当にこれだけでコーラ作れなことがちょっと今日は試してみたいと思います
初3つを焦がしたカラメル
うわぁすげぇなるほどですねハッチーは西洋版を出すために使うらしいですね
penang
さあでもすげえなんかネットで作った人が何人かいらっしゃるんですけどもみなさん
コーラだって言ってるんですねすごい潰したパック家にライブの窯を絞るだけでも行っ
たりコーラの氷塗っ
あのとなるほどまずはなく髪率取れず長根した方が安そうなんでねしてきます号第2を
やっていきましょう
まーやー
焦がした蜂蜜って書いてあったんでも壊せばいいと思うんですよねアニメ中だと相当
原始時代の作れてたんでそんな難しいをだしなくていいと思うんですよね
弱そうな10水ってるなぁすごいすぐメって充実してるこれ絶対焦げてるいい感じで
こんなにカラメルソースを入れちゃいます
なんかポイントぽいぞ高すぎホットケーキみたいなニューになってきた
でも色的にはなんかコーラっぽいぞアイテムで焦がしたはず実はからベルソス混ぜてみ
ましたこれでたがあってる気がしますしこれで第一かもはクリア
覚醒に悩むかけるだけでもコーランの空3がするってくれちゃったねそれやってみ
ましょう
まずパックと潰さなきゃいけないですね先っぽが張っただけちょっと撮ってみましょう
か
[拍手]
ん
言え a crew
[音楽]
ん
はぁんん a 4の a なったところで
ああ今とパクチーって銃弾時 x 安易なこれ独特すぎるなにこの s に変わるな
感じでいいけどのパクチーにライブ汁かけたらなんかほら風味がてるって書いちゃった
後でやってみようと思います
まあめっちゃ綺麗に切れたハサミでもかけていきます
持った
パーッ
ああああ絶対無眼鏡かけてたほうが良かったま
[音楽]
どうでしょうこれでも風味がコーラになってると書いてあったもん
ありません
ぽいんだがえっまたじゃねぇ
捕逸ゲーかコーラのなんか匂いになってる
poco poco で動い動きはそれじゃあさっそく蜂蜜焦がしカラメルソースと
パッチーライムソースれたん男性混ぜてみようと思います
[音楽]
は6分
a 怪物ができたんだからこれも含めてコラなんでしょうねというわけで完成しました
ずカフェコーラーでございます引用元ドクターストーン
なんか中のカラベラ書かずに固まってるんですけどもなんかすごい独特な臭いになって
ますけども畑ってあんの方はどうなってるんでしょうか
竹100%コーラにつけてこれはそそる税
[音楽]
鳳凰
こうラガーはすごいすごいすごい僕の中の勝手にハードル上がっちゃったせいであれな
んですけども
何って言われたら絶対コーラって答えはずになってますはすごいなあ
ごちそうさまでしたすみませんこれはすごいあのちゃんとコーラの味がしてました
すべてにおいてコーラ母がちょっとありましたいやーすごかったしますけどちょっと
普通のコーラと飲み比べてみると
こちらいいや
me
あっはぁ